plus que temps de tous les dangers s'est
finalement tenue dans le pays alors
qu'une dizaine de deal n'ont pas pu
organiser le vote
l'arrivée de la coalition patriotique
pour le changement la cpc qui ont
attaqué ces villes veulent en effet
faire échouer la volonté du gouvernement
centrafricain de maintenir les scrutins
on peut d'ores et déjà noter une grande
mobilisation malgré la psychose dans la
ville de bangui mais aussi dans
plusieurs villes dans dubai en proie aux
violences armées dans d'autres villes du
pays les vous armés se sont clairement
opposés au scrutin et en brûler comme
dans la ville minière de carnot des
jeunes à la fin du scrutin
malgré tout le président sortant poster
quand je dois déjà appelé les 180 à
vampire leur devoir citoyen et à voter
massivement l'appel a par exemple été
suivis dans des quartiers tendu comme le
p45 à bangui où plusieurs groupes
d'autodéfense sont encore opérationnels
et où nous nous sommes rendus en journée
la mobilisation il ya été
particulièrement importantes
les observateurs électoraux
internationaux mais aussi nationaux ont
par ailleurs noté que le scrupuleux que
le scrutin s'est tenu dans des
situations déjà imaginé mais dans un
calme relatif à bangui l'ancien prison
for françois bozizé a pourtant appelé
dans un message audio diffusé sur les
réseaux sociaux à un boycott du scrutin